ça à toutes et à tous hello one of the
year je m'appelle angela là et j'espère
que vous avez passé une belle journée on
m'a pas
j'ai eu l'occasion de rencontrer
beaucoup de personnes aujourd'hui
bonbons ce moment hors du principe que
les décharges rythme nos quotidiens
l'énergie qui en découle de toujours une
portée vers le haut depuis ma plus
tendre enfance
l'humain ces relations ont toujours été
au centre de mon parcours et de mon
éducation
je me considère un peu comme un une
sorte d'électron libre
si la chance de voyager aux quatre coins
du monde et a toujours à la recherche un
peu de défi libre de reconnaissance et
de compréhension
alors j'ai grandi à cuba entouré de
soleil de musique et de femmes ma mère
ma grand mère a tenté d'en nombreux
jeunes malgré un contexte socio
politique que vous connaissez plus on
entendrait jamais jamais à cuba se
plaindre et ce n'est de la chaleur après
je ne sais pas si vous savez ma cuba
premier moyen de transport et le stock
de part et d'autre de la rue vous verrez
souvent des personnes attendent de
quelques minutes à quelques heures
une âme charitable et amène à bon port
alors en voiture pour les plus chanceux
à la benne d'un camion et quelquefois en
calèche et l'entrée est de mise en
permanence dans ce pays en permanence
mais c'est surtout et toutes personnes
s'y présente s'étant déjà radio à cuba
peu de confirmer c'est surtout le payer
et commandes bien et rythmé bon à part
les télés les telenovelas équivalent de
netflix
c'est surtout la musique véritable
source d'énergie positive qui entraîne
les personnes au rythme des percussions
grands jeunes vieux et j'en passe jour
et nuit au rythme de la musique
c'est ce qui fait notre énergie après je
tiens à dire que tu bats c'est une
véritable time capsule véritable tatem
capsules ou et qui nous pousse en
permanence à voir cette simplicité de
vie
cette joie de vivre et la volonté de
koné connecter avec les autres alors dit
souvent que ce sont ses racines et ses
origines du cou qui qui me pousse à
impulser cette dynamique positive tous
les jours alors être en relation avec
les autres ça va un peu se connaître soi
même
passionné de sport j'ai dédié plus de
dix ans de ma vie à l'athlétisme alors
commençons par les cross du collège
jusqu'aux produits nationaux et les
sélections en équipe de france et avec
ses engagements et la chance de beaucoup
est âgé de rencontrer des personnes
abusent de m'enrichir à chaque fois et
j'ai pas mal souffert parce que je ne
sais pas si vous savez mais les sportifs
on est un brin sadique tout petit feu
toujours à la recherche permanente de
permanents pardon de cette énergie et de
ce dépassement de soi mental comme
physique
alors quoi coureur de 400 mètres j'ai
souvent rencontré ce mur ce mur
invisible pour rencontre sur la laine de
la dernière ligne droite qui nous coupe
littéralement les jambes et où seul le
mental vous poussez vous portez du moins
jusqu'à la ligne d'arrivée
sportivement c'est aux états unis que
j'ai grandi et a entouré d'un coach qui
par la suite devenu un ami se porte ce
coach a pu m'a donné les touffes comme
disait souvent les clés de me dépasser à
l'entraînement et de m'accomplir et de
en quelque sorte de rendre cette
compétition un jeu parce que finalement
le sport c'est du plaisir avant tout
la performance n'est que la conséquence
de cette dynamique
alors y avait une petite histoire
souvent quand on arrivait à
l'entraînement il y avait des sites
attirent un peu partout très américain
il y en avait une qui disait que j'ai
retenu à force de havas elle disait oui
oh what would do they know is not
tonight habite alors assis durant dix
ans j'ai façonné mon corps j'ai souvent
et mon mental après l'écouté la
compréhension de moi même entre
l'adversité et le respect de mes
adversaires et la richesse du tout
toutes ces rencontres alors l'espoir en
compte c'est une belle école de la vie
où la réussite s'inspire de l'échec ou
la persévérante alimente les sens de
l'effort et houle aventure et les
partagera les choses uniques comme dit
souvent mon coach de l'autre côté de
l'atlantique
keep moving et désormais je me trouve
face à vous
à paris france un pays au sein duquel se
trouvaient là moi une certaine quiétude
pour accompagner par des personnes que
je considère comme des mentors et
visionnaire et après tout tout tout ses
aventures voici phil woods leader
certains discipline et ce qui est bon
travail de phil woods leader c'est un
peu une une découverte quotidienne ou
l'adaptabilité de mise
permanence et tel un baromètre j'écoute
échange je partage avec toutes
absolument toutes les personnalités qui
pour nos équipes
imaginez l'adversaire mais je trouve que
c'est une superbe opportunité d'avoir un
job a créé ou inventées du mois où le
plaisir de l'aider mais aider les gens à
être vaut être bien dans leurs baskets
chien
et investit dans ce qu'ils font alors
imaginez moi titubant partie de cuba
sans rien mais avec l'amour de mes
parents et surtout de la mer je n'ai
cessé d'aller chercher au fond de moi un
peu cette force nécessaire pour me
dépasser et toujours c'est le curseur un
peu plus loin parce que nous savons pas
toujours nous allons agression mais il
faut oser être authentique et s'entourer
de personnes de confiance
alors chaque expérience nous apporte
quelque chose des rides
vous pouvez doutez vous allez goûter
certains mais ne baissez jamais les bras
parce que je trouve qu'il faut être
ouvert faut trouver aux autres mais sur
toile inconnue un peu plus difficile et
vous faire confiance par confiance alors
la havana miami votre bain jusqu'à paris
à l'effet des virages m'ont dit j'ai
mûri j'ai évolué encore je pense que
j'écoute ou je continuerai jusqu'à la
fin je donne du sens mon sens du moins à
cette aventure que j'appelle la vie une
fois ce que ma mère dit est souvent et
continue on utilise souvent à la maison
qui disait la huila et son carnaval
une chanson de celia cruz toujours bercé
mon enfance je vais finir en dix ans
vivez l'instant présent très important
faites vous confiance et aimé
[Applaudissements]